allez tous à comprendre dans les mains
alors même que la photo k
c'est parti
tous
demain jusque là
tu es loin et j'ai mal et marc fesneau
l'ange du marchand là ça n'allait pas de
moyenne et de michel hockey
parce qu'en fait c'est l'orangé du
marchand alors j'ai juste on est bien
d'accord je suis pas michel
l'homme était connu c'est pas ton pote
nico il fais pas ta star là elle avait
10 40 euros pour la presse c'est ça
aurait quand même pu prendre quelqu'un
de vraiment connu que genre faudel puis
ah ouais ouais ouais
herman une grosse mais à venir
depuis hier 23 heures un forcené a pris
en otage les employés de cette
entreprise de photocopieuses l'identité
du suspect est encore inconnue mais
merde je suis pas un inconnu
je suis connue ok passez-moi mégaphone a
pas mon cas c'est bien la voiture
ok écoute moi qu'est ce que tu peux pour
leur serrer d'hôtes à trouver l'argent
tu as dû cacher là on n'a pas le budget
pour ça va mais c'est moi qui pars est
en écoute moi n'écoute pas lui c'est moi
qui parle
non mais j'étais chanteur moi j'ai fait
de la télé réalité je veux juste qu'on
trouve quelqu'un qui me reconnaît c'est
chaud c'est chaud là franchement ça va
être chaud tu préfères pas de l'argent
serve à ça va être plus facile pour nous
à 1110 coni c ur sérieux notre
négociateur beaucoup de pays refusent je
peux te faire rompre l abbé raven gens
comme toi là et du coup je dois dire que
je passerai la télé ça serait formidable
c'est toi stéphane costes manager
magazin sétois ce nom était une star et
tout je suis trop fan
d'ailleurs tu peux me l'a dédicacé s'il
te plait je demandais un peu trop bien
dire gardien a faim
à
dommage que latéral
mon coeur
esma tu es loin et j'ai mal